pendant de longues années roselyne
bachelot avait décidé de mettre un terme
à sa carrière politique
suite à la grande polémique suscitée par
l'achat massif de vaccins contre le h1n1
qui s'était finalement avérée inutile
l'ancien ministre de la santé était
revenu sur le devant de la scène
présentée comme la femme qui avait tout
anticipé j'ai eu à gérer des crises
pandémiques
forte de cette nouvelle image après des
années à chroniquer dans différentes
émissions
roselyne bachelot est de retour en
politique mais du côté de la culture
cette fois ci on est redevenu ministre
malgré de nombreux interviews une
présence médiatique très forte la
ministre semble impuissante face aux
décisions gouvernementales cinémas
théâtres salles de concert tout est
fermé depuis des mois sans exception et
sans solution mais c'est une souffrance
une ministre qui semble être présente
sur tous les fronts sauf celui de la
culture
roselyne bachelot a choisi une veste à
113 euros car une communication
excessive et peu productives qui agace
de nombreux artistes alors roselyne
bachelot en fait elle trop alors qu en
fait elle trop c'est la question qu'on
pose on a pas mal de d'unités regarde on
va voir la réaction déjà de pascal praud
un pascal praud cette semaine qui n'a
pas hésité à égratigner la ministre de
la culture gars violent
bonjour à tous à quoi sert roselyne
bachelot ministre fantôme de la culture
oublier ce bien un essentiel que le
gouvernement méprise sa cage assassines
madame bachelot promène son blues sur
les remparts des théâtres fermés des
musées cadenassé ou d
cinéma verrouillé elle dit qu'elle
souffre dit qu'elle n'est pas aveugle et
sourde puisqu'elle comprend les uns et
des autres blabla pour amuser la galerie
paroles et paroles
hélas roselyne bachelot chante phone
n'est pas dalida qui veut roselyne
bachelot ne sert à rien elles portent le
cercueil de la culture comme il est
acquis que les croque morts n'auraient
vous dites non au jeune fille comme je
trouvais qu'elle est à sa place mais je
trouve surtout que pro on a fait
beaucoup beaucoup il est juste là il ya
eu du tac face à tirs à balles réelles
c'est pas normal
alors ce que j'aime chez les choix qu'on
aime il dit les choses
ce qu'il se passe quelque chose et
cartonne ouais vous n'aimez pas dire les
choses si ça va être clash et non mais
il peut le dire les choses différemment
effectivement il ya un vrai problème et
pour la culture moi je suis la première
à défendre la réouverture des salles de
cinéma la réouverture des salles de
théâtre etc etc
y'a rien qui se passe et rien ne bouge
alors elle vient d'annoncer ce matin
qu'elle allait peut-être se mettre sur
le système qui s'est passé en espagne
barcelone où il ya eu effectivement un
concert test avec tout le monde sait ça
elle a annoncé cette possiblité de
mediapad annonce donc pour une fois
qu'il ya une annonce une possibilité
peut-être on peut plus beaux films et je
préfère la nomination de pascal praud
moi qui est plus tranché il faudrait
l'arrêter alors fait trop parce qu'elle
n'est pas la vérité elle ne peut rien
faire a les pieds des mains n'a pas
pieds et poings liés église et point
livre dont elle est parée par les moines
y est vous l'a dit les épier dit elle ne
peut absolument rien faire moi c'est une
femme que j'aime beaucoup je pense
qu'elle ne sort pas elle n'a pas pu
encore montré ses capacités parce que
forcément et à aimer c'était le bordel
et je pense sincèrement qu'on peut pas
lui faire de faux procès maintenant
pourquoi ouvrir plus les restaurants que
les salles de cinéma sert même que la
bbc que je pense sincèrement que
malheureusement cette dame est et elle
ne peut rien faire elle peut suggérer à
n'a pas à l'ap à la main sur les crédits
ils ont faire en sorte que les
intermittents soient efficacement
protégé une saison plus qui plutôt bien
mais c'est pas elle qui va décider c'est
l'économie est allée à la palène la
question que j'ai envie de poser au
tessin moi je l'avais comme chroniqueuse
rosine la chaux franchement elle est
très sympathique et comme chroniqueuse
elle fait le taff et on lui demanda
presse eric roselyne voilà l suivant
alité voilà quoi sarko dit elle avec
emmanuel macron bon ça voilà c'est ce
que j'avais déjà dit mais elle est très
très sympathique on chroniqueuse moi je
me suis éclatée avec elle et elle est
très facile à travailler cela pracon non
pas du tout franchement cela racontait
pas voilà après c'est vrai qu'elle suit
le vent on regardait les t elle
participer aux grosses têtes aussi
regarder il ya quelques semaines un vrai
bonheur que de revenir ici dans ce
studio avec grand et avec peu tappero
vous aurait proposé la santé vous auriez
dit non non non non non non on ne se
baigne jamais deux fois dans le même
fleuve
j'espère qu'il sera partout björn à
virus en janvier inch'allah comme on dit
vous avez vous avez le droit de revenir
en porte le grosse tête ou pas anodin
non dits dont les gamins font garder ma
place au choix parce que va naître
holistique et aurait alors une question
qui a été drôle c est ce que vous allez
droit de revenir aux gros set mais est
ce que quand on attire autant de télé on
a le droit de revenir au gouvernement
aussi c'est la question qu'on peut se
poser parce que rose et wigan et on a vu
là on va l'avoir
alors c'est aussi les rênes du shopping
regardez l'extrait
[Musique]
ce
oh
les belles bleues co2
[Musique]
alors oui oui colle à bois alors d'abord
je suis pas du tout d'accord et c'est ce
que vous avez dit avec pascal praud
moi je suis totalement d'accord avec
pascal praud il ya peut-être été un peu
formel mais son attitude aussi il ya
aussi ce méga la fois la fin je voulais
vous d'ailleurs ce que je voulais vous
dire c'est que je pense qu elle n'est
pas bonne mise avec culture en pleine
crise de co vide c'est à dire on
retrouve un peu la roselyne bachelot qui
se travaille sur les plateaux un peu
partout et que je pense que la situation
est grave crime de temps en temps il
vaut mieux ne pas prendre la parole que
d'aller un peu partout sur les plateaux
télé quand on n'a rien à dire ce que je
vous dis je pense que vous avez raison
mais je pense qu'en ce moment elle n'a
rien à dire un peu comme un ver ans
environ il passe chaque fois un peu
après la bataille
c'est aujourd'hui elle a rien à dire
elle ferait mieux de faire des choses en
back-office essayé de parler avec les
différents acteurs théâtre et autres et
de ne pas aller se faire médiatiser
parce que je pense qu'aujourd'hui elle
aime l'antenne c'est ça la réalité je ne
serais pas allé aux grosses têtes par
exemple s'offrir le moment d'aller aux
grosses têtes
adam foote field animateur qui entre à
décines il en est ce que vous avez vu
comment alors on regarde je rends rugby
va pas rendre l'antenne laurent ruquier
par exemple vous avez vu comment ils
s'adressent elles s'adressent elles un
peu comme ça c'est un peu compliqué elle
est munie de la culture dans un moment
de souffrance mais pas trop elle rame
trop elle essaye de faire le maximum
pour faire bouger les choses mais ça
bloque à matignon donc elle essaye bleus
cowboys à matignon que ça bloque l essai
de lever et de sauver les meubles
parce que ce qui était reproché à
l'ancien ministre de la culture franck
riesser ne pas assez être présent pour
soutenir la culture même si il n'était
pas possible du stress énorme et vous
parlez dans le
ça tire ça le problème alors c'est quoi
moi je me dis que ce qui serait bien
c'est comment un peu plus d'assurance
dans ses interviews histoire de rassurer
un peu les gens et tout simplement ça
sera bien qu'elle essaye de trouver de
nouvelles pistes nous on attendait
qu'elle trouve de nouvelles choses au
lieu de répéter bêtement ce que le
gouvernement lui dit de dire tout
simplement je pense mais elle a dit si
je disais autre chaude je mentirais au
monde de la culture et de nos citoyens
quatre cinémas du tout au rien faire oui
mon gars là à les nier que c'est une
femme de culture elle aime la culture et
vous apportez saison le gouvernement a
dû tout annuler lui a alors lu non parce
que j'ai vu je regarde j'ai remarqué un
truc oui c'est que verront en fait son
anagramme est et ce qu'il est il est
toujours d'après non mais c'est vrai
merci à roselyne bachelot c'est une
femme de culture c'est une femme très
compétente à ne peut rien faire comme
l'a dit benji c'est vrai elle est pieds
et poings liés
voilà c'est bien compris mais attend ce
qu'il faut reconnaître c'est que
effectivement elle ne peut rien faire
voilà donc c'est tout ok peut rien faire
alors il ya des gens qui se plaignent en
crimée des français quand même
elle est vraiment aimé des français
roselyne bachelot bref vous la trouvez
vous à moi j'aime bien sûr jérôme parce
que c'est une femme naturelle tu vois ça
la culture même s'il est très cultivé je
pense qu'elle n'a pas sa place à la
culture parce que c'est là où est
peut-être je pense pas que c'est là où
elles excèdent le mieux je pense alors
là elle arrive aussi ai je crois que
c'est là la milice de la culture c'est
arrivé c'est là c'est la pire chose qui
puisse arriver à la preuve qu'elle a une
crise à gérer que personne n'a eu à
gérer avant il ya un spot michel moder
qui me dit j'ai un café 4 et un comédie
comme à marseille sur le vieux-port je
passe mon temps à aller chercher
où sont ces [ __ ] de subventions ils
sont annoncés à coups de millions
centaines de millions d'euros millions
par bachelot et compagnie mais nous
mourrons
voilà mais le docteur nous dit que tout
va bien donc voilà il ya là les gens
voilà c'est vrai nom du spectacle ils
sont dans un marasme absolue donc
roselyne bachelot en fait être ok vous
voulez rage et rouillée magali babin je
trouve qu'elles cassent un peu les codes
et j'ai l'impression qu'on a tendance à
tirer facilement sur les femmes
politiques qu avec marlène schiappa
comme avec tout autour
devant le tir sur tout le monde n'en
verront ils sont plus en plus avec
l'anti s'adresse aujourd'hui à cette
femme à roselyne bachelot je trouve très
vulgaire et arrêté des élites c'est
pareil avec tout le monde
il a fait pareil avec veron qui a fait
c'est son style j'ai l'impression de me
défendre moi parce que je suis ainsi
pied bien sûr rien dire tant d'erreurs
mais un peu ce qui se disait
c'est vrai et michel polac tout ça y
avait entendu dire s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît merci non mais c'est vrai que
voilà après mois le joug dit le truc de
dire il s'attaqua on vous parle pas
comme ça il parle à une ministre un
ministre
voilà et illies vous pascal praud voilà
il essayait dans ce rôle on peut le
faire parfois c'est vrai qu' il part en
cacahuète c'est ce qu'on aime aussi je
pense le matin après voilà après que ce
soit nice aurait été un ministre je
pense il aurait parlé même chose comme
ça c'est une très bonne émission savait
moins c'est pas la peine donc ça m'a pas
j'adore mais je suis pas d'accord avec
la violence quand on m'a chaussée la
poterie fait dire fait le même truc que
sur la voilà sur des trucs qui peuvent
se passer ici où parfois il ya des gens
qui disent ouais si c'est un peu trop
mêlé excellent style de l'émission et
que c'est ça qu'on aime ou timochenko
sont anéantis voilà je vous le dis quoi
c'est vrai que le monde de la culture
c'est comme les restaurateurs c'est
exactement la même chose c'est à dire
que c'est un aujourd'hui par des
intermittents c'est exactement pareil
les intermittents alors ok on leur dit
que les silos chaude cette heure les
intermittents donc ils les opticiens
l'exemple aux jeunes arrivant à lille
ont ramené de 12 mois vous êtes trop
techniques et chirurgie dentaire dont il
bouffe pas abrogée déjà bien sûr celle
d'une couverture voilà c'est un film et
puis il ya des gens qui se retrouvent
ils n'ont pas eu le temps de finir leurs
dons qui sont dans le sol il faut
grandir